[Music]
[Applause]
mankind and the elements
for some
it's an uncomfortable bond
in bad conditions it can be a death zone
for others when weather strikes
inspiration begins when you build an
instrument out of it you're kind of
bringing that tree back to life for this
creating music
these are the people who challenge
nature
seek out its limits
reveal its secrets
and embrace its awesome power
in this episode we'll meet a team of
imaginative foley artists creating
sounds of weather for motion pictures
your ear hears snow
but in actuality it's sin
a hawaiian family who's made world-class
ukuleles from rare koa trees for decades
not only a beautiful wood but kind of
symbolizes the family
and two brothers who bike in some of the
most extreme environments known to man
it's steep and it's gnarly and that's
just an extra bit of danger which is
always a plus these pioneers are the
great outdoors ahead and that's amazing
[Music]
in hollywood everything is magic and
make-believe gloves with paper clips are
dog paws even what you hear we are
storytellers with sound over here we
have a feather duster
used for bird
bird wings
we bring sound into the story and we can
create any mood with that sound when you
watch a film
much of what you're hearing was created
[Music]
from footsteps on a snowy path
to a vicious thunderstorm
weather is a really interesting thing to
recreate and make it exciting it depends
on the elements that we're using and how
it's filmed and what they want to hear
here at the warner brothers lot foley
artists practice their craft
and if they do their jobs right you
won't even notice people take sound for
granted
but you would miss it if it wasn't there
foley is the art of sound it's
creating sounds in sync with what's
happening on screen
the art of foley goes back to the old
radio days where you would see the sound
guys with their clomping with their
coconuts this is what we use for horse
hooves they're
plungers
and we stuff them with cloth and a
little tape
and here we go
jack foley came in and he thought if i
do those sounds in sync with the picture
i've just taken a whole step out
jack foley's legacy and sound began in
the 1920s as talky swept hollywood ever
since the reproduction of sound effects
added to film in post-production is
called the art of foley the foley stage
consists of different surfaces this is
walking on leaves or in a forest
for snow what we normally use is regular
play sand
and then to add to that
sometimes you hear that familiar crunch
which we use cornstarch
your ear hears snow
but in actuality it's sand
[Music]
it's almost like a prop house we have
collected
different things because everything here
should make a sound here's a classic
squeaky hinge
pine cones can be used for cracking ice
you have the three people that are on
the stage the mixer and the two foley
artists which
it's important that you have a team
that's cohesive you know something's
cracking popping i don't know what it is
is it this
it takes a little trial and error to see
what works best hold on we have a
streamer that goes across the screen and
when the streamer gets to the end
that tells us when that sound should
start
[Music]
it's an interesting dance
there's really
nothing that we can't do here
imagination-wise
right now we're in the control room and
it's where i mix and i listen to
them performing to the picture i try not
to look at them
because i really don't want to see what
they're using i want to see how it
sounds
all sound is two elements hitting one
another with rain if it's hitting a
puddle or if it's hitting someone's face
that's all going to sound different
so those are very specific little things
that we have to watch and look at
okay mary jo here we go
wind is interesting because it's usually
what the wind is blowing through
allison's gonna use the batman cape to
create the sails and i'm going to create
the boat actually going through the
water okay let's go
if we're doing a boat going through
waves
we would use the big tub that we have to
get that slapping sound
or churning up the water a lot in the
tub with our hands
it's a lot of sound like like a lot of
things artistic is very subjective so i
have to make that judgment call
there's a great moment when you get the
perfect sound and they don't always know
it but i do how was that mary jo sounded
great when there are multiple weather
elements involved we might do all the
specific things first
and then go back and do maybe a general
sound we have a shot here of a hiker
coming down the
waterfall so i'm doing the sound of the
carabiner and his
rope and his equipment
how was that that's cool
so i'm going to play it back all
together and see what we've got
we really layer everything
so the mixers can mix how they want to
hear it and we do things also that are a
little over the top
because we have to fight with music
sometimes dialogue
but hopefully when you hear it at home
it'll sound
just like it should be natural
on eli malk island in palau there is a
lake like no other
it's called jellyfish lake
this stunning saltwater lake is roughly
12 000 years old
and was once connected to the ocean
but as the island changed
it was closed off
now
in isolation it is filled with a
jellyfish species found nowhere else
the golden jellyfish
these cryptic creatures spend their days
migrating across the lake following the
path of the sun
and with no predators to keep them in
check the jellyfish swarm and fill the
lake like a cloudy dream
it's safe for humans to swim here
because though the jellyfish do have
stingers they are too small to be felt
by humans
gliding through this place feels
otherworldly
[Music]
grass is something we take for granted
we walk all over it lay on it
and sometimes mow it down
most of us don't give it much thought
few of us appreciated the way that dan
harvey and heather ackroyd do
i think we create these pieces partly
because we just love actually the magic
of seeing them in print and come to life
and grow the british artists blur the
lines between science nature and art
by manipulating the nature processes
that fuel life itself
to create their canvases
you're actually imbuing it with this
energy and creating with with life and
they're almost dayglow images when you
first see them they're very very
beautiful
[Music]
so we're standing on leith hill
which is near our home town of dawking
which is about a mile down the road it's
an area of outstanding natural beauty
geologically the area is green sand dan
as a child used to come up here with
this father born and bred here and spent
a lot of time up in these woods
in the forest dan and heather come
across a group of activists protesting
plans for oil drilling nearby
and decide to document their cause
weren't you just looking straight
straight into the lens they take a
series of photographs with the hopes
that one can be used for a grass
portrait
if you actually look at what's happened
in the last 25 years if you look at
what's happened in the last five years
mega flooding scenario severe weather
events are happening time and time and
time again and increasingly more
frequently and the science is very very
clear and unambiguous about this our
work is very much embraced around
processes of change around nature around
biodiversity loss around climate change
from the very first time that dan and i
started to work together it was you know
it was within our site it's not
necessarily a direct action or activism
sometimes pieces are very very poetic
it's a bit dark around the eyes
i should do that
i actually think it's really nice
we got you know we spend so much time
together you know it's like 24 7 really
isn't it we work together live together
we have a child together we challenge
each other's ideas and thinking but
that's really good because it kind of
makes i think it makes our ideas more
robust
so i printed these ones off
i
really like that one
i think that's the one
we've been together 26 years and
we still
yeah i think i mean when you're when
you're a couple who live and work
together the thing is that you actually
really don't switch off it's just like
this kind of charge there's always a
charge to what we
[Music]
do maybe only do one
one or two photosynthesis works a year i
i think what's interesting is is that
we're we're not working with lawn or
with sod or with tuff we work with with
the seed
dan and heather germinate their seeds
for about two weeks
when ready they're rubbed onto the
canvas
held in place by water paste we're not
carving or sculpting in that more
traditional sense you know we're growing
the image sort of develops over
over the period of weeks to grow one of
our pieces we grow the grass vertically
then we turn the whole of the studio
space here into a dark room and so the
only light that the grass receives as
it's growing is from the projected
negative image so where the strongest
light hits the grass it produces more of
the chlorophyll more of the green
pigment where there's less light it's
less green where there's no light it
grows but it's italiated and yellow so
you get the equivalent to a black and
white photograph but in terms of green
to yellow
portraits we tend to do around six foot
by four foot or maybe seven foot by five
foot in this case we can work really
really large scale and what's great
about that is that it's not it's not
sized in a gratuitous way actually the
resolution we get is really really
extraordinary it's phenomenal if you
equate a chlorophyll molecule with a
pixel then we're getting kind of like
many more pixels
for kind of like you know kind of like
square footage you can get on the large
ones is absolutely fantastic it's part
of a process of discovery you know as
artists you're looking to make
discoveries within the materials and
mediums that you work with and you know
light and seeds
water
crystals all of those are kind of part
of our palette or materials that we play
with if watered regularly and kept at
low light levels these grass portraits
can last indefinitely
there's something about seeing the way
that they grow and they sort of
materialize in front of you really and
you don't really get to see them until
the last moment really when when you can
put the lights up
[Music]
oh wow
grass me up
i feel that this piece has got a real
strength
about it you know i think the person we
photographed in their youth
just has this real kind of connection
with the camera and he's somebody who
cares
passionately about what he's doing it's
like a watercolor color grazes through
it you know it's very very beautiful i'm
still a bit taken aback by how it's
grass
i know i know
we're really really pleased to that
we're really pleased the way that it's
grown
[Music]
sam and joe flanagan are brothers
who take mountain biking way past
extreme
we love doing anything we can possibly
do on our bikes the extremer the better
the gnarlier the better they're not too
interested in well-worn paths or typical
trails it involves climbing up a snowy
hill then so be it that's a good
afternoon spend
one big problem we did face was a lot of
frosty equipment instead they hike and
bike down some of the highest
snowiest
and coldest mountains in scotland
the kingdoms on a beautiful day can be
an extremely rewarding environment in
bad conditions it can be a death zone
[Music]
our childhood was always really really
active so we'd always be out climbing
there's a lot of caving around here in
yorkshire both my parents were
into the outdoors so they they got us
into sort of stuff like mountain biking
climbing caving from an early age
and
we just sort of fell in love with it
because we lived in a rural area
mountain biking was just a natural
progression
the mountain biking we do would be
classed as extreme because of
the elements that we do it in the places
we do it in
the kind of stuff we're riding down it's
it's not your average trail centre it's
steep and it's gnarly and
it's just an extra bit of danger which
is always a plus
joe definitely does take more risks to
me he loves the climbing side of things
and that is definitely a lot more risky
if we're in a place joel definitely
would be the first one to take the risk
formed 40 million years ago
the cairngorms is a mountain range in
the eastern highlands of scotland
it is home to five of the six highest
mountains in the country to say the
weather is extreme here would be an
understatement
it's prone to wind speeds of over 100
miles per hour
temperatures well below zero and of
course the occasional avalanche
not exactly the typical choice for
mountain biking
first time that i wouldn't have climbed
was with joe shooting the winter climb
ride um it was up aladdin's couloir in
the king gorms so that was it was
definitely a baptism of fire when we
were setting up and looking around to
try and scope in the area it was blowing
an absolute gale it was a really white
out conditions you couldn't really tell
where you were going it's impossible to
remove the danger from mountain biking
completely because you're still out in
the elements there's rocks there's
slippy surfaces you're always going to
have your little crashes and your
tumbles
the kingdoms can be on a on a beautiful
day can be an extremely rewarding
environment and really beautiful to
behold but in
bad conditions it can be a death zone
and many people have died up in the
kingdom plateau either being caught out
by bad weather or
falling off a cliff it can be completely
like another world of of cold and
extreme weather up there
definitely when it's snowing icy you
need to 100 check the weather you need
to make sure that everyone's going to be
safe detailed information on what the
weather's going to be like up high what
the wind speeds are going to be like
and it's dangerous there's a lot of
people have to get rescued there's a lot
of people unfortunately are killed in
the hills around the caring homes
because they misjudged the weather
one of the main reasons of riding down
the snowy icy mountain is everything's
just heightened everything's more slippy
everything's that little bit more scary
coming down is the best feeling that's
where you feel really free you just
wind blowing through your face and
carving turns in the snow it's just
unmatched
speed wise you on the snow you can pick
up kind of 30 40 miles an hour without
even thinking this stuff just starts
blurring past but that's the best part
a load of adrenaline
i love blending my activities blending
my sports and
adventurous biking i'd like to push push
on
i think i will adventure until i can
adventure no more until my
body allows me to to go no further
as mum good friend craig evans always
says death before download if you're
gonna have to carry down it you're just
gonna try it anyway just get it done see
it through
[Music]
scattered across the new mexico desert
are buildings that look like something
from another world
[Music]
they are homes
designed to be completely self-sustained
generating their own electricity water
gas and food
they are the life's work of an
unconventional architect mike reynolds
who believes homes are the key to a
better future
[Music]
we came up with the name earthship
because
houses have to have gas lines coming in
sewage lines going out electric lines
coming in and so these buildings provide
all of that themselves these buildings
address comfortable shelter electricity
water sewage treatment garbage and food
michael reynolds started all this after
the oil crisis in the 70s once the
prices went up
that meant everything we had to buy just
went up so this house is basically
trying to make us less dependent on all
these things
i came to taos right after architectural
school in 1969.
this climate is super severe it's real
hot in the summer and it's real cold in
the winter so it's a perfect place to
test pilot these buildings so that you
see if they can stay warm in severe
conditions and cool in severe conditions
reynolds vision has grown there are now
7 500 people living in earthships
worldwide but constructing the
self-contained buildings isn't what
you'd call easy
it comes down to a complex system of
sustainable materials and construction
there are mountains of automobile tires
everywhere all over the world well why
don't we make a use for tires
the tyres give out the foundation of the
house and also the structural walls the
tire will not rot termites don't eat
them they are resilient for earthquake
and at the same time because they're
packed with earth inside it's going to
accumulate the heat it's like a
heat battery it sucks up heat and then
it gives it back to you
when the temperature of the room drops
you do feel really nurtured inside some
of these houses because inside the
living space the temperature is the same
all year round
then we have plastic and glass bottles
we cut them in half and we put the two
bottom ends together
it means that we'll be using much less
cement because we're using this other
material which compensates at the same
time it's going to let light come into
the house you can do combination of
colors so you can do mosaics
[Music]
living off the grid in the desert
creates challenges for basic water needs
but the answer to this problem is one of
earthship's most elegant solutions for
the rainfall we've only got about eight
inches of rain a year
so all the roof is dedicated to
recuperate this water and harvest it
this rainwater after we've used it once
let's say through the shower will go
into the botanical cell then it's
basically irrigating plants and then
only after that does it go into the
toilets so we never use
the water and the toilets directly from
the rain we've already used it twice
we retired in september of last year
we've been here full time since
[Music]
it gives us freedom from bills it gives
us the ability to go back to our natural
roots and live and love the seasons here
we actually got a newsletter sent to us
from michael
and then we decided we'd come out here
and stay in one of the airships lo and
behold i saw this little mud house here
for sale so that's how we came to this
point
this community itself this earthship
community is full of eclectic people
there's people here from
everywhere
i think that with time we're seeing more
and more people who are interested in it
but also who see the advantage in the
long run especially you know to take
care of our planet so we want to try and
have these bases all around the world
and be able to continue training people
there directly
reynolds and his team have been sharing
their designs around the world
developing earthships in places of need
i can't possibly build all the buildings
that need to be built on this planet no
i want it to be a virus people get
infected and they infect more people and
they infect more people that's the way
this can grow a standard earth ship
costs roughly 235 dollars per square
foot
and comes in a range of sizes
i lay in bed sometimes awake at night
can't wait to get up the next morning
and keep doing this we're building we're
drawing we're traveling doing education
michael reynolds and his team have
helped many individuals and charities
build these off-the-grid homes around
the world
i plan to keep going until i drop but
i'm already seeing that it doesn't
matter when i drop there's people that
are just going to keep doing this
there are roughly 3 000 earthships
globally which house around 7 500 people
[Music]
freediver to me is a pioneer
we're all experimenting in something
that has not been the main trust of
humanity until now
my name is aaron solomons i'm a free
dive instructor trainer from ada i
specialize in coach
athletes who want to do national records
or world records
you've got to kick in your dive reflexes
breathe up a little bit uh breathing
about
as you do just before you went to sleep
then one big breath turn over and go
from the moment that you leave the
surface
the blood is beginning to leave the
peripheries and migrate towards
so-called noble organs
then you start to sink faster and faster
once you're free falling it's pure
pleasure it's an incredible sensation of
restlessness
[Music]
you're going down and the colors change
go down from a clear blue here
to a darker blue
and to
the purple twilight
and then finally into total
blackness then we have a rude awakening
hit the play and then we turn around and
we have to work a bit harder coming up
as you come up you're working less hard
because buoyancy is returning
and then it's like a rebirth you're
coming back into the light
the whole process is one pleasure
and a terrific sense of adventure and
achievement
usually changes in switches
all the things that i thought were
impossible
all the things that i thought were not
achievable by me
are
if that's achievable what else isn't
achievable and that opens a whole
pandora's box
so it's quite an experience freedom
[Music]
in the shadow of mauna loa
on the island of hawaii
the native poetry roots in shallow
volcanic soil casey ako isn't found
throughout the hawaiian islands but
nowhere else
today it is probably the most valuable
hardwood found anywhere in the world
acacia koa is native to hawaii
named koa meaning brave and bold
it is prized for its incredible beauty
color and curl
it enjoys the humidity of the tropics
requiring nearly 200 inches of rain per
year to thrive we like to leave these
big grandpa trees let them throw seed
for the forest and hopefully pass on
more trees for future generations to
honor the iconic symbol of the islands
those who harvest koa almost never cut
it down
allowing mother nature to decide when
and which to harvest as the wind blows
it doesn't take much an above average
wind will knock some pretty large koa
trees down the higher quality
instrument grade koa is used for making
ukulele and guitar
for 100 years
the kamaka family has made world-class
ukuleles from these native trees
working with nature to try and create
a certain voice is truly something
special to me
inspiring music and musicians
recognized far and wide as distinctly
hawaiian the modern ukulele was truly
invented by the kamaka family using
techniques passed down for four
generations the kamakus hope the koa
tree will provide
another hundred years of song
[Music]
my father never claimed to be an ukulele
player he made instruments because his
friends did
and he took what he learned and opened
his ukulele guitar shop
my father was he was a perfectionist i
remember him saying don't make junk
ukulele became the most prominent
instrument in hawaii
most businesses
don't last
beyond maybe the first two generations
but we've been to the fourth generation
we managed to keep it together
this sound is a little fuzzy
the sound today
cleaner more precise it better be you've
been working on it for 90 years you have
to show improvement the factory has been
a home away from home
everyone
here
pretty much raised us because we were
running around the shop from when we
were young kids
you know in hawaii family's such a big
thing
and
they're part of our family same like
with our musicians without them we
wouldn't be here and that's how
we hoped that they would feel
[Music]
a koa tree is in the pea family it's a
legume and it's a pretty hearty tree
[Music]
on our ranch of the coast zone it starts
at 4000 foot elevation and goes up to
about 6500 foot elevation
the koa that we have milled here
probably some of the most beautiful coal
i've ever seen
our growing conditions are pretty
optimum
kona has a really unique
weather pattern mauna loa dominates our
climate
when this huge land mass heats up it
draws those ocean currents mauka and as
the mountain cools
and nightfall comes
the dynamic shifts and now this wind
blows makai
the root system for the koa is shallow
root in this volcanic soil not only is
that susceptible to wind but there's a
herd of cattle that came through here
they'd be trampling the roots and kill
the tree
our logging operation is centered around
harvesting windfall trees trees that
have fallen
and so for the most part we can pretty
good business just with windfall trees
[Music]
i used to bug him all the time dad take
me to go look at the wood
all i'm doing is envisioning this
instrument coming out of that log
this stack it's about a board foot per
instrument
yeah so that's about 400 ukuleles right
here i guess you can say i'm cheating a
little bit because i'm using what mother
nature has given us
when you build an instrument out of it
you're kind of bringing that tree that
you saw up there back to life because
it's creating music
so when the wood finally gets here after
we've picked it from the big island we
dry it out in back it takes at least two
years
for the water naturally to come out
from that point the wood is
picked cut
sanded the thickness
put into production
it's bent you know the interior is all
braced
it's glued together
where you have the body
the neck is built
once that's built it's glued on
we fret the instrument
and then it goes into finish process of
filling and spring lacquer on it
once it's dried we glue the bridge on
tuners set up get the action correct and
then it's ready to be played
[Music]
my dad started his ukulele shop as a
hobby
and it's been going
for a hundred years
we love
to hear the good sound of the ukuleles
though
creating that has been a lifetime of
service
to the people of the islands 100 years
is a long time keeping people singing
[Music]
the ukulele is it's the symbol of aloha
you know it represents hawaii represents
the culture here
i get to take the ukulele all around the
world to share a little bit of hawaii
with the rest of the world and it's such
a beautiful thing for me there's a very
unique sound about it and when you hear
it you know it just just makes you smile
i wouldn't be the player i am today if
it weren't for their instruments
[Music]
iceland is home to the largest glacier
in europe
and an abundance of wild freezing cold
water
which makes for a unique fishing
experience for those willing to try it
steyani ben
is a fly fishing guide
who doesn't hesitate to wade into
waist-deep glacial waters
all for the thrill of the catch
favorite part is always the take you
know when the fish takes the fly
adrenaline just goes off
just
casting
running your own business and all of a
sudden
that's a lot of fun
we're at thunderfield
which is a sea turtle river on the south
coast of iceland
this river is known for for very big
fish
i think it's because of all the glaciers
and this is fairly new geologically all
this part of the country
[Music]
the river is not very fertile and that's
why we have sea trout in there
they have to go to sea to get something
to eat
and there's not a lot of people who
would enjoy this
it's fun being fishing in this kind of
weather we'll be breaking ice off the
road all the time you know because this
wind chill and the world gets wet
once you have your first fish it it
starts to be a lot more about nature the
river
getting away from your normal life
i don't know just being outside that's
what it's all about
you know
fly fishing off is a never-ending
journey so to speak although it sounds
like cliche
you're never gonna master it no matter
how how hard you try no matter how much
time you spend doing it you're never
ever gonna master it
i love it offers non-stop
challenges new challenges
[Music]
when i was younger i used to think that
architecture and art and science were
all completely different disciplines i
mean the older i've got i've come to
realize there's a lot of similarities
there's some gray areas i think between
kind of art and architecture the hive is
an installation created by artist
wolfgang buttress it's been built in the
royal botanical gardens in london i
wanted it to fit really comfortably in
its landscape so it almost looks like a
swarm the swarm of bees
and then the closer you get to it it
reveals its sort of structure
the sense of kind of moving from chaos
to the kind of the order and the beauty
and the harmony of the honeycomb the
lines and sounds inside the hive are
triggered by the activity of a real
beehive the busier the beehive
the more intense the light and sounds
so i first heard about the hive i read
about it actually in the newspaper and
the purpose of the hive is to tell the
story of the role of bees in pollinating
crop plants and therefore feeding the
planet and i thought that was perfect
for cube because we want to bring alive
why plants matter and clearly one of the
most important things that plants do is
they feed
humanity
dr benzik placed an accelerometer inside
a real beehive
these accelerometers measure the
vibrations and energy of the beehive
the hive is connected to the sculpture
and its activity is expressed through
light and sound
the hive itself
is really
telling the message about why bees are
important they're important to society
because they help pollinate food or
provide the food that we eat but they're
also a very important part of our
ecologies our ecosystems
the honeybee is responsible for
30 of all the food that we eat
but the b is in crisis it's it's dying
in unprecedented numbers because of
climate change pesticides lack of
biodiversity
i really hope the visitor will have a an
emotional experience you know something
which kind of connects them to nature i
think sometimes you can say a lot more
by being quiet and sometimes we forget
how powerful important sounds and touch
and smell are so to me that was really
important that these elements were at
the heart of the installation
thousands of people continued to flock
to kew gardens
to view and experience this 40-ton steel
honeycomb
an ode to the plight of honeybees
[Music]
you